in this video we're going to talk about
arrays and about objects quick
disclaimer objects in JavaScript are not
exactly the same thing is objects and
some other languages that
object-oriented languages so if you're
familiar with another language and
you're thinking wait that's really not
an object I know we're talking
exclusively about objects and JavaScript
in this video what makes an array an
array are these square brackets here
here we declared a variable array with
square brackets that's what I want you
remember for arrays inside of an array
you could put anything you can put a
string you can put a boolean you can put
a number you can even put another array
and have a nested array you can do that
as many times as you want that's totally
okay as far as objects there's a little
bit of different notation notice the
curly brackets here in all of these
strings here we have key values and the
property values you might see this
referred to as JSON JSON that stands for
JavaScript object notation a lot of
times if you'll be making an API call
something you'll learn about later the
information you'll get returned will be
in this format a JavaScript object
notation technically you can even have
an array of objects what I want to
remember from this video is arrays
square bracket that's just a set of data
and objects curly brackets more strings
and objects you have keys and properties